[Música]
ahora cuenta con más de 150 millones de
usuarios estadounidenses pero el futuro
de tiktok en Estados unidospende de un
hilo un número creciente de legisladores
quiere prohibir la Popular aplicación de
propiedad china estos influencers y
propietarios de negocios fueron al
congreso para mostrar su descontento
mental para acelerar mi defensa y sé que
no estoy sola
en realidad me ha permitido aumentar mis
ingresos un 700% Y estos ingresos extra
me han permitido mantenerme construir un
estudio y pagar el personal y si me
quitan esta plataforma no estoy seguro
de si podré seguir haciéndolo
directora ejecutivo de tiktok testifica
en el congreso el jueves la
administración del presidente Joe biden
ha exigido a los propietarios chinos de
tiktok que vendan o se enfrenten a una
posible prohibición la aplicación ya
está prohibida en todos los dispositivos
del Gobierno Federal pero muchos
funcionarios no creen que vaya lo
suficientemente lejos temen que tiktok
pueda pasar datos personales de los
estadounidenses a Beijing censurar
contenidos e influir en los usuarios
acusaciones que la empresa niega Los
Defensores de la plataforma sostienen
que no es más propensa las violaciones
de datos que otras aplicaciones que
recopilan información personal
existe un problema real y deberíamos
abordarlo incluye a tiktok Facebook
Twitter Instagram y otras plataformas
sobre nuestros datos la privacidad de
nuestros su venta y sobre permitir la
desinformación Pero eso no es lo que se
aborda cuando la gente dice que quiere
prohibir tiktok
Lleva años en el punto de mira del
gobierno estadounidense los tribunales
bloquearon un intento anterior de la
Administración Trump de prohibirlo en
parte por considerar que violaría la
libertad de expresión eso significa que
cualquier medida para bloquearlo
probablemente dependa de la aprobación
de la ley restric un nuevo proyecto que
reforzaría la autoridad del gobierno
para prohibir la tecnología extranjera